it is time to talk news i wanted to save
the the
to keep the intro to a minimum because
we are about to go off
on this jury finds derek chauvin guilty
of
murder no swearing no swearing i
couldn't believe it dude no i could
believe it i absolutely could believe it
the jury was threatened
maxine waters threatened the jury the
rioters threatened the jury
and there are left-wing journalists
right now saying
the only reason we got this verdict is
because we spent months out in the
streets and i'm like
they're even admitting it it was the
threat of violence and destruction
that resulted in the jury saying derek
chauvin should go to prison
on second degree murder now i will i
want to be fair
they're getting on the felony murder
rule arguing that it was assault against
george floyd
and because it was felony assault and
george floyd died therefore it's murder
okay i think there's maybe an argument
of assault but this is what
really makes me think this is nuts we
watched the video
in great detail the defense showed the
video george floyd was resisting arrest
a bystander even said
you can't win man just get in the car no
joke the prosecution and the defense
show that in closing arguments
a guy yelling to floyd to stop resisting
some random bystander
so i'm sitting here like why is the
prosecution showing george floyd
actively resisting
and bystanders saying stop resisting so
you mean to tell me
that a cop is trying to arrest somebody
for a counterfeit
for potential under under the influence
and now resisting arrest
and it's assault if the guy says hold me
on the ground hold me on the ground hold
me on the ground like george floyd did
and then chauvin holds him on the ground
and they say that's felony assault
oh and he died murder now he's going to
go to prison so i'll tell you this
i'm not a big fan i'm not interested in
defending the state
or police institutions as a whole my
interest is is in the individual
derek chauvin and his rights and i'm not
happy that you know about what happened
to george floyd but i will tell you if
you've got a problem with the state and
the system and the policing
take it up with the state the system and
the policing but now you know it
happened
the state literally won it was the state
of minnesota
versus derek chauvin and the state won
their case why
because leftists extremists activists
went out
burned down their city left us
journalists are the ones saying this
they're being on the ground and engaging
these activities resulted in this
verdict
maxine waters making these threats and
so the jury sided with the state
chauvin's one man you got a problem with
the actions of an individual officer
that crossed the line by all means hold
him accountable
but chauvin is acting as per the rules
of the police department
arrest somebody if they commit a crime
if they resist arrest here's the force
you can use
i don't see how throwing one man under
the bus is gonna solve any of these
problems
and i still think we're gonna see riot
so nothing gets solved in long run other
than a bunch of weak and terrified
jurors
who just say guilty because i'd rather
not have my house burned down
i i think i agree with obama that it was
not justice
uh and uh alexandria cortez yeah but
justice
obama but right you're taking it the
other direction yeah i am taking it the
other direction barack
because it wasn't barack obama
said true justice is about much more
than a single verdict
aoc said this is not justice because
they need to keep the grift going
they need to always be angry well think
about i mean think about everything that
led up to
all this i mean even when you look at
the riots and all this
when you have people that are not firm
on people going to jail i mean we saw
massive amounts of damage millions of
dollars
this was obviously incredibly
politicized and then to your point about
maxine waters
when you have all these kind of like
tectonic plates almost
uh building up this pressure and then
ultimately have
you know the the media on talking about
this and being in favor of
the way it should go quote quote unquote
and then you have politicians speaking
out
and then on top of that all the civil
unrest that's kind of really creating
this
this uh pressure um it really
is concerning on who is choosing
uh you know is this gonna happen
a lot i mean when does it when does the
the writing and the
everything that led up to this when does
it end
you know the one the one uh they say you
know what god closes the door he opens a
window
the one thing i can see is i think the
second amendment's about to get a whole
lot stronger
if these if these people are going to go
out riot i really don't see why they
would not
because you have the dante right
incident as well so they're not going to
be satisfied with just this
i think it would have been way worse but
now i can only imagine more liberals are
going to be like
need to buy a gun so i guess there's
that at least
in it to your point i tweeted this
or i should say i tweeted this and it
works to your point i said let this be a
lesson to all police
you will be charged you will be
imprisoned when i saw that story about
uh kim potter is her name i think the
cop and the dante right thing i'm like
why is she why is anyone surprised this
is happening to her
i think if you're a cop watching this
happen to chauvin and his other officers
and you choose to stay there hey man
it's a free country you do what you want
to do
but there's only so much i can do to to
defend you
when you know what the mob wants you
know the politicians are going to give
it to them
and you know there will not be a fair
trial you expect to
to get passed through this i don't think
so well we're seeing so much
of a i mean at all campaigning i i talk
with a lot of law enforcement
we're in such a you know back the blue
type of area where
you have so many people either retiring
from the la from the police force and
law enforcement
people they have shortages now people
don't even want to
join uh the force and i think eventually
i mean these things need to be done in
an honest way
and and that's just not being it's just
not happening right now
it's it's perfectly in line with what
the left wanted right defund the police
abolish the police and if that doesn't
work drive the police out
with threats and intimidation and terror
the court of public opinion is making me
nervous
it's it's really powerful i knew it was
powerful in 2006 when i saw youtube
videos and that you could get 50 000
people to call somebody
at the same time on the same day yeah
and then the next day do it again
or order pizzas yeah just in it and it
causes serious
problems take all your money out of the
bank at the same time on the same day
just crash a bank
on any given day any youtuber i mean you
could do that
and i know these are mutually exclusive
but also why was it encouraged
i mean you had encouragement on on the
the blm and the riots and the protesting
from from all these different angles as
well and i know it's
a little different from the actual you
know verdict today but
these things are being encouraged and
that is a big problem
at what point are are your elected
officials going to stand up
and say no
it's not going to happen until regular
people say something and they won't
because they're scared
mm-hmm so i you know we we ian and i got
an argument this
the other day where i was like if the
people of
minneapolis the twin cities of minnesota
will not personally stand up and say
i support the police and this is wrong
then the police have no support
now you can whisper it to your friends
ain't enough these people don't want to
put blue lives matter flags up they want
to put american flags up because they
know they get targeted
okay then the squeaky wheel gets the
grease the reason why it's being
encouraged
major corporations know there is no
opposition if they come out
and they what ben and jerry's ben j ice
cream company yelling at me about racist
cops
like i don't care dude you guys make
cookie ice cream i i
don't need to hear from you about the
police department it's fine i guess i
don't care market how you want to market
i just think it's absurd that someone's
like i'm gonna start an ice cream
company
and my marketing pitch is you're a
racist and evil buy my ice cream
but the reason they do that is because
there's zero opposition so what's the
downside
if they come out and they say go riot
and go in the streets
no conservative will do anything they
might complain about it i mean we did
have the conservatives burning all their
nike gear when colin kaepernick took a
knee but for the most part they don't
so conservatives are staying home
minding their own business not
organizing
and the major corporations the big tech
companies and the politicians know their
only threat is from the left so they
give the left whatever they want
normally if you were to tell people to
go riot which is a crime
i mean i don't know rioting is a crime
well the word riot
that that's not necessarily a crime
right you have to massage the truth
again
get more confrontational yes walk faster
when people are burning down buildings
tell them to do more be more active
like it's supposed to be illegal to
incite violence but to have
maxine waters telling people if we don't
get a murder one charge which he wasn't
even charged with
or a conviction for murder one which he
wasn't charged with that we should
what she what was her quote do you guys
know offhand that we should push harder
that we
should get we should get more active and
get more confrontational get more
confrontational she's talking to rioters
that's
she's and they're still out there right
now so that they're that right
right now as they're marching around i
don't know exactly
if it'll escalate or what the deal is i
got to tell you man
i kind of i i i wasn't really expecting
a verdict this fast
i re i might my video today was like oh
they're preparing who knows when the
verdict will be and
my my over at teamcast.com and then i
get a text and it's like the verdict is
coming in an hour and i'm like
what it's been a day it's not even i
think it was 10 hours of deliberations
yeah it was so short so when i when i
heard that it was that fast i was like
it's either going to be
guilty on all counts or not guilty
accounts it is too soon for a hung jury
there's no way the jurors went in and
they were like half of us are fed guilty
and half are for not guilty and we'll
never change our minds okay let's go
home hung jury
too soon so i was kind of like maybe
it'll be not guilty because
they're bringing in the national guard
in downtown minneapolis right now
they're
why would they be moving the national
guard and i'm like so it must be not
guilty
then i heard guilty and i'm like they're
they they knew the verdict was guilty
and they're still bringing in the
national guard you know uh ben shapiro
tweeted something
amid all this he said the fact that i'll
paraphrase the fact that we all knew
that our cities would burn based on the
outcome of this
of this trial so it's it's an indictment
of
of our country or society or something
that effect yeah that's absolutely true
of where we are now what but it even
goes into
what happened recently with you know
georgia and just kind of all these
policy measures that
people are are choosing sides and
corporations are choosing sides and
people are being kind of pressured again
where you're seeing this on
every type of and
politics is infiltrating kind of every
aspect of our lives now
and and i don't think it's ever been
that way and it shouldn't be that way
but but did you see what happened with
coke like didn't come out and actually
say like georgia's voter law new voter
law is racist
and then conservatives were like uh
we're gonna buy pepsi and they went wait
wait
we must find common we must find common
ground see that's the thing
concer so the republican party is has
much less people than the democratic
party
it's shifted quite a bit in the last
election it started to invert
democrats are joining the republicans
republicans are doing great recruitment
but you mostly have moderates and
independents that sometimes lean right
that's how republicans end up winning
these people don't do anything they
don't speak up they don't say anything
they keep shopping
coca-cola could you know could pepsi
literally made a commercial
where their protesters going around
handing out pepsis
and they see no repercussions for this i
mean actually the woke left got mad at
him about that so they had to like
apologize for
having was it kendall kendall jenner
kendall that it was oh yeah
no is it kylie i don't know i don't know
any of these people i never watched that
handing out pepsis
it's this simple conservatives aren't
organized
moderates don't organize disaffected
liberal types
actually there's a decent amount of
distracted liberals who are speaking up
but by nature as a disability liberal
they're complaining about something
so long as this group is just like loose
knit and passively in agreement but not
actively going out talking about things
standing up going outside
then there's no downside it's it's it's
the it's uh uh
do you guys know what pascal's wager is
negative you you do
you do right so it's basically this dude
was like
if i believe in god and
i die and it's none of it was real or
true
then what does it matter but if i
believe in god and i die and it is true
i get to go to heaven
he says now if i don't believe in god
and it's not true
it doesn't matter and if i don't believe
in god and it is true
well then i go to hell so your safest
bet is to be
you know believe in god or be religious
it's not necessarily a fantastic
argument but i bring this up because we
have what i call
i'll call the critical the critical
theorists wager or the social justice
wager
if you are on the right and uh
you know you stand up for your rights
you will likely be canceled or banned
if you are on the right and you do
nothing nothing happens
you end up losing the left ends up
gaining ground if you're on the left you
stand up for what you
and you don't stand up for what you
believe in the left still charges
through gets whatever they want
and if you're on the left and you stand
up and scream you will likely get
whatever you want so
you're celebrated right so this this
this wager is very obvious
if you want to run a business right now
in this environment
your best bet is just to feign leftism
because there's no negative
repercussions
and that's awful because you look at
and you make a really good point because
you know commerce and business and
services and products these were things
that were supposed to unite us
as americans or unite us as people
right when you're going to ben and
jerry's well nowadays now you are asking
well
what were you talking about in politics
but before you're like i just want my
double chocolate chip ice cream
you could sit down into ben and jerry's
and look over to a random stranger and
be like which one you get
right now it's like who'd you vote for
to the cashier even
i mean that's what it turns into oh what
i'm researching every
single company that has spoken out and
what are their
their stances now and it's awful and i
and
it's it's bad because as a somebody who
works in business
our product for example helps kids and
that's it
and it's like well is it that's not
republican or democrat you're just
trying to
you're trying to create a product and
you're trying to solve an issue and
you're and there's a demand for it
simple as that
it's supposed to unite us yeah so you've
made the point that politics has gotten
into everything and this is something
that troubles me as well this is not the
way it's supposed to be
and the fact that we have to do things
like ask who did you vote for
that creates suspicion it weakens our
society from the bottom up i hate to see
it
i i look at what happened with with
chauvin and the one
thing i think the perspective of the
left is that like
all cops all the time are abusing their
power and they don't understand
like why arrests happen and they keep
saying things like
if if derek chovin didn't put his knee
on george floyd's neck
then floyd would be alive today the
prosecution
act is actually debunked very early on
two things the eight was it eight
minutes 46 seconds was debunked
it's actually longer it was 9 minutes 29
seconds i think it was but the other
thing that was debunked was that the
knee was on floyd's neck the whole time
it wasn't
in the video you can actually see some
in some periods the knee moved off the
neck
but the left uh i mean they
they want to believe in these uh
tribalist
i don't i don't i honestly don't know
why they don't they don't investigate
they don't read the stuff
they just assume whatever the media says
is true i see them paired on social
media
and then what you get is blind rage in
support of the tribe
you know the leftist tribe no matter
what i was talking to a friend of mine
and she said uh
you know i i don't even wanna talk about
what we were talking about but she was
like i'm just gonna accept it
at face value and i was like yeah you're
just gonna believe the first thing they
tell you
the government and she's like i just
don't have the energy to
investigate and and that was
that was it i'll put out i do i'll put
it this way
they say that george floyd would uh
still be alive if shoving it put his
knee on his back
george floyd would still be alive if he
didn't resist arrest or do drugs maybe
yeah or take a bunch of fentanyl maybe
maybe maybe you would have killed a kid
and
got behind the wheel of a car and drove
into some family walking across the
street yeah
he was doing drugs in the car it was and
the the defense made an interesting
point that we don't know how much
fentanyl he took
the the north fentanyl in a system was
the metabolite of the fentanyl he had
already taken so
that means he had taken some like a long
time before this incident occurred
so look i'm not happy about what
happened i don't like the idea that a
cop is trying to arrest somebody and
they die
the cops shouldn't be killing people and
there should be a level of scrutiny the
issue i suppose is
this will not reform the police
department it won't i guess what the
left is going for
is if you can't beat them burn them to
the ground if they can't get
the police department abolished then
they're going to try and force
every cop out and right now i gotta say
the smartest position for the police is
probably just to leave what is this
are they like okay this is high
conspiracy but is this like a corporate
takeover like do they want
private police the squad you see that
breaking story you saw you see that the
squad members buying all the private
security oh of course
yeah this is like turning into a third
world country
uh you know my family my mom came from
guatemala and
they have the private police force now
overtakes the public police force
because you don't really know
you know whose side the cops are on it's
not
meaning to laugh but it's just you get
to this point where it's
you're seeing elements of that here in
you know the greatest country in the
world and this is what separates
us from these
third world countries i'd be willing to
bet
a bunch of our libertarian and anarchist
friends who've been on the show are
going to be cheering for the idea that
the police will crumble from this
because they genuinely believe private
policing is better i'm not one of those
people i'm i'm fairly libertarian little
l not big l
i'm leaning slightly to the left and i
think the reason the police department
works is that they're neutral arbiters
they're not perfect the individuals can
be racists the individuals can be
bigoted
we want to we want we want to deal with
that we don't want those things lawsuits
exist as well and there's a challenge
with poverty
when somebody who's poor gets pulled
over and they can't afford to pay a
ticket then they go to jail it creates a
cycle it's very it's problematic
but when you have two people fighting
and a cop walks up he's not there to be
on anyone's side like is it the laws
that's what you did
go away or you're under arrest right
well in aoc and the squad
they all talk about equality and you
know no classism and all this well
that's exactly what they're trying to do
when you talk about private police
forces who
is able to afford a private police force
obviously people
who are wealthy and have money but then
yet your
your policies and what you talk about
all the time is about equality and
no classes and yeah and all i mean it
just it's completely
it's complete hypocrisy to t
this is what will happen they will
defund the police they will use the
chauvin case
as as an example and they're going to
march and they're going to say c
and then once the police are defunded
the rich people who don't care
are going to hire you know g4s or
securitas or something
and they're going to have a couple guys
in suits with glasses outside their
house and they're going to worry about
anything
we talked about this last year during
the riots you know private security
would actually punch a cop on your
behalf
if you get if you get a legit private
security company these guys are getting
paid
you know low to mid six figures
depending on who the client is right
these guys they're wearing suits they
got sunglasses ear pieces
legit security for high profile
individuals if a cop tried arresting
these security guards would put shove a
cop to the ground they'd they would
absolutely assault an officer because
they don't respect
some guy getting 30k a year in new york
city or 40k when they're getting 400k
and they're working for a prince or a
celebrity
they're like nah this guy's got billions
of dollars he'll bail me out i don't got
to worry about it
my company will take care of me so when
the police are defunded
and they don't respond to the calls of
the poor people anymore who suffers
well it's going to be the black
community it's going to be latino
community right it's going to be the
poor community in general
and the rich people are going to be
sitting there in their infinity pools
not caring well they just found that
something
i want to say something like 80 percent
of people who are surveyed these black
people in these communities
want more police presence right they
don't want the police to go away
well it's the same thing with the
hispanic community when you look at you
know voter demographics i mean i
come from a you know 40 miles outside of
the city of chicago where you're seeing
very high crime rates all the time
nobody's talking about that crime
hush hush right they talk about these
kind of instances that happen
uh every once in a while
but the same thing happened in the
hispanic community which is why a lot of
people started voting more conservative
because they come from countries where
there is no law and order they're
leaving these places where
they don't trust their law enforcement
we
again have that public trust
and and they're you know people are
chipping away at that
i love i love the idea of socialists and
leftists
condemning the state right now when the
state literally won its case
the state versus derek chauvin the state
is the winner
they're complaining about their i see
these tweets they're like
it was an agent of the state who
committed a murder and it's good to see
they should not be allowed to do that
and i'm like
it's the state who also won from the guy
to the bus also
if you're a socialist and you want
socialized everything
yeah then shouldn't you be happy with a
socialized law enforcement
system thanks for checking out this clip
from the tim cast irl podcast if you
want to see the full
show come back to this channel
youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at 8
pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time